[Musik]
15 uhr
er ackerte in brasilien pünktlich wie
jeden tag setzt auch heute die sprengung
in der goldmine tonnenweise arsen frei
der staub verteilt sich im ganzen gebiet
lage ist schlimm genug das wissen wir
schon wir wissen wir müssen wissen was
mit der gesundheit passiert mit
einzelpersonen die partnerkarte leben
basiert
und leider ist es nach acht jahren
nichts passiert
dani ist arzt seit jahren treibt ihn die
gesundheitssituation um die goldmine um
immer wieder gerät er deshalb in
konflikt mit der kanadischen minen
betreiberin davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
doktor sérgio ghani der brasilianer
arbeitet heute als assistenzarzt am
kantonsspital st gallen in der abteilung
onkologie findet das wöchentliche
kurzreferat stadt jede assistent soll
dabei ein thema das ihn besonders
beschäftigt vorstellen
heute ist doktor dani an der reihe und
das ist ein open cut wie gesagt das ist
sehr problematisch weil das liegt
praktisch in der stadt also es gibt
keinen boundary also früher waren auch
die borussia dann auch stadt wie trier
wurden einfach vertreten abgebaut
für die mine und das ist ganz ganz
problematisch meine arsen fressen
termine innerhalb einer stadt eine
90.000 einwohner stadt sehen das gift
par excellence
das lässt aufhorchen das ist sehr sehr
wenig gold für sehr sehr viele sehen
also das verhältnis ist unglaublich
unglaublich ungünstig dass ungefähr ein
kilo arsen protonen ärzten dafür
arbeiten diesen tonne erz 0 4 gramm gold
ist ein glaube ist es handelt sich
eigentlich um eine nasenlänge nur gold
als lumpen
dani ist einer der wenigen spezialisten
weltweit
er hat ein verfahren entwickelt um den
arsengehalt in den knochen von patienten
zu bestimmen
damit kann er chronische arsenvergiftung
nachweisen was sonst überaus schwierig
ist ein besonders dramatischer fall
beschäftigt ihn seit langem
sie hat sogar die firma angeklagt und
ich wurde angesprochen
deswegen war als asienspezialist ihrem
wohnhaus liegt 200 meter von der
goldmine entfernt hat immer staub und
offensichtlich auch gas
geatmet mit 19 jahren wurde sie
schwanger und hat sich ab der achten
schwangerschaftswoche eine progressive
erkrankung entwickelt die dazu führte
dass sein kind in der 22
schwangerschaftswoche tot war
doktor dani arbeitete zwei jahre lang in
pará kato und kämpfte dort unermüdlich
gegen die andauernde verschmutzung ein
ungleicher kampf arzt gegen großkonzerne
als er sogar bedroht wurde zog er nach
europa ans aufgeben aber denkt er bis
heute nicht
er reist immer wieder nach brasilien
diesmal kann ich ihn begleiten wir
fliegen nach belo horizonte
dani aufgewachsen ist hier aber fühlt er
sich wirklich zu hause
seine familie stammt aus paraguay ferien
habe ich immer auf diesem gebiet hier
verbracht
cowboys mein großvater
hat eine große farm
und er hat nie gezüchtet wie viele
andere
damals war nicht die zeit der dass der
soja plantage das war erst in den 18
artigen jahren also die landschaft hat
sich seitdem sehr sehr dramatisch
geändert
um dieses paradies zu schützen als er zu
seinen anteil am familienbesitz in ein
naturschutzgebiet verwandelt die
stiftung ak in der sprache der
eingeborenen heißt dass kopf des wassers
das reservat dient auch als
wasserschloss für die stadt baraka to
die bloss 30 kilometer entfernt liegt
flora und fauna wie zu urzeiten
[Musik]
unmittelbar daneben liegt die rinderfarm
der tante und seiner schwester der tour
vermisst seine rinder das pharma leben
schöne erinnerung aber auch schlechte
nachricht ja natürlich streiterei mit
jäger mit finger gebissen worden von
tollwut infizierte hunde solche sachen
auch auf tiere war gehört dazu am
mittagstisch erklärte dani seinem neffen
wir weiter kämpfen will
die ganze familie soll es hören jetzt
betreten wir eine neue bühne jetzt geht
es vor den internationalen gerichtshof
ich bin mir ganz sicher er wird ganz
euphorisch in seiner mission
vielleicht kann man jetzt die mine
schließen denn bloß 30 kilometer weiter
wird in der goldmine tag und nacht
gegraben
sieben tage die woche
es ist ein moloch mindestens ebenso groß
wie die stadt paris die grube
mittlerweile vor zehn jahren stellte
kinross ein gesuch zur erweiterung der
mine die bezirksanwaltschaft beauftragte
den arzt sagte dani die gesundheitlichen
folgen abzuklären dabei stieß er
erstmals aufpassen habe ich keine ahnung
sehen überhaupt vorhanden war ich war
keine geologe aber dann musste ich
untersuchen und dann bin ich auch
aussehen gestoßen arsen ist zwar
natürlich in die grabsteine drin aber es
wird nicht freigesetzt die tätigkeit der
minen macht dann asien frei und das ist
das problem
da sind wir ein großer menge freigesetzt
die umwelt
wir haben natürlich empfohlen die minen
nicht zu erweitern
weil es wurde natürlich mit freisetzung
von sehr großer mengen von arsen
einhergehen
aber das hat sich hat mich genutzt
dieser im film hat keine wirkung gehabt
die behörden haben
trotz dieser warnung die das per
mitgegeben die erlaubnis gegeben
daraufhin klar zerschoss stiftung die
kanadische minenbetreiber in ein
kinderhaus soll dazu gebracht werden
eine systematische untersuchung zu
arsenbelastung durchzuführen dass die
staatsanwaltschaft in der lage und die
uci wies auch in der lage waren die
firma dazu zu zwingen
zu dieser klinische studie mit dem
virtual studien sie haben das natürlich
nicht gemacht anstatt dessen haben die
dann ein team ein forscherteam auftrag
gegeben um eine medizinische
untersuchung zu machen wie waren nicht
qualifiziert in die gar keine ärzte die
haben dann chemiker geologen auftrag
gegeben die haben alles gesagt und
geschrieben was das schon bekannt war
und die medizinische anteil wurde nicht
gehandelt
die aufnahme von einem freund zeigt
sagte daniel radikalisierte sich er
hinderte die fahrzeuge aus der grube
daran durch die stadt zu fahren und den
arsenhaltigen lehm der an den blues
klebt überall zu verteilen
er wird von der militärpolizei verhaftet
in einem wagen der wohl von kinross
stammt kinross spendierte der politiker
in einer feierlichen zeremonie mehr als
einen viertel ihres wagenparks kinos ist
überall präsent zum beispiel auch wenn
etwa die kirchen fassade renoviert wird
heute ist sonntag im radio city läuft
das programm ranulph ohne war nun vor
ist eine institution in pará cato seit
mehr als 40 jahren kommentiert er das
lokalgeschehen er kennt stadt und
umgebung bestens seine eigene rinderfarm
grenzt an die goldmine
er kritisiert kinross oft hatte er keine
angst vor repressalien angst doch schon
etwas
ich weiß ja nicht was im kopf der leute
vorgeht ich kritisiere aber ich mache es
immer ganz klar
mir geht es um die liebe zur umwelt auch
die studiogäste reden klartext wie
zattoo als er 2008 zur an ulf eingeladen
wurde
wir sehen daher gehört der kirche in der
kirche war nicht zufrieden mit dem mit
dem ergebnis weil die kirche bekommt
auch geld von kiriasis öffentlichen das
ist nichts gibt kein geheimnis und der
die kirche wollte nicht exkommunizieren
oder wie heißt das auch deutsch erst
kommunizieren wollte mich
exkommunizieren dafür aber jetzt ist es
anders geworden weil die beweise dass
dass das ein problem vorliegt sind sehr
sehr offen und sehr streng und die
können nicht widersprechen wäre
lächerlich
auch für die kirche
eine arsen patientin die seit langem
betreut wurde ins spital eingeliefert
neben der sorge um ihr wohlbefinden sie
zu die möglichkeit einmal mehr einen
eindeutigen zusammenhang zwischen ihrer
krankheit und asien aufzuzeigen
als wir ankommen ist sie bereits wieder
entlassen
wir machen einen hausbesuch die
patientin wohnt knapp 200 meter neben
termine chronischen vergiftung kann
verschiedene krankheiten verursachen
herz und kreislaufprobleme
nervenerkrankung zuckerkrankheit
leberschädigung lungenkrankheit bis hin
zu verschiedenen krebsarten bis die
symptome aber für den laien und sogar
für unvorbereitete ärzte erkennbar
werden kann es jahre lang dauern
das ist sebastian abba groß sie ist 48
jahre alt bereits bei ihrer ersten
untersuchung hatte sie deutlich erhöhte
arsen werte sie leidet unter diabetes
und unter taubheit auf der ganzen linken
seite der doktor widmet ihren füßen ganz
besondere aufmerksamkeit
was man hier sieht ist eine vermehrung
von bindegewebe sogenannte hyper
keratose und außerdem sieht man auch
eine verdunklung der so beide sohle holt
kleine wunde hier und da da hier das
sind typische veränderung von
chronischer sind drucksituation
das wurde schon passen mit der
geschichte mit einer lese mit der
laborergebnisse gesamtbild
gesamtgewichtes gibt und das würde ein
normaler praktizierung gewachsen
die sollten das genauer schauen vor
allen dingen denn es
denn ein fahrrad besteht dass das ist
wirklich ein typisches bild wie man
früher oder noch heute in bangladesch
länder wie bangladesch oder in die
gebiete wo sehr viel arsen im wasser ist
in klink was uns erwartet in paraguay
wird seit 400 jahren gold geschürft
die stadt ist quasi auf gold gebaut ihre
gründer waren die goldgräber die
sogenannten gar in berus der abbau war
damals jedoch handarbeit goldwaschen in
den bächen und flüssen und dabei wird
keiner sehen freigesetzt durch den
industriellen abbau wird in der hausse
mit ihren rasch fallen die
lebensgrundlage entzogen
wer schon nimmt mich mit zu einem der
sich für die belange der gare in perus
einsetzt den stadtrat dragos olivera die
kinross hat zwar die lizenz für gold
abzubauen
aber sie musste gebräuche die
umweltbedingungen und die sozialen
strukturen der hiesigen bevölkerung
beachten
kinross soll die bedürfnisse der gabi
peters respektieren
sie sollen es doch halten wie in kanada
dort müssen sie auch die rechte der
ureinwohner wahrnehmen der goldabbau in
der mine ist nicht besonders effizient
40 prozent des goldes fließt mit dem
giftigen abwässer in die auffangbecken
ab das macht die brühe für die
goldwäscher attraktiv sie enthält jedoch
neben dem ansehen auch blausäure kurz es
ist ein giftiger cocktail trotzdem
steigen jede nacht bis zu 600 gharib
eros in das dreckwasser eine gefährliche
angelegenheit
in den letzten sieben monaten sind
wieder drei menschen in den röhren
gestorben
die todesursachen waren alles andere als
klar
stadtrat rados wollte es genauer wissen
ich bin mitgefahren zur autopsie
da lag dann lucimar mit übernahm carrera
ein anerkannter führer der gold schiff
er organisierte die gern in peru
es wurde schon lange gemunkelt dass er
aus dem weg geräumt werden sollte nun
will er so einen augenzeugen zu den
letzten vorkommnissen befragen
das erweist sich als recht schwierig die
gar in perus scheuen sich davor offen
auszusagen
wir werden hin- und hergeschickt bis ein
anwalt seinen mandanten überzeugen kann
zu reden das ist paulinho
er ist 25 und west seit sieben jahren
gold aus der giftbrühe wie kann das sein
pedro hat so viel sicherheitspersonal
und die können auch nicht davon abhalten
kann ich denen das erzählen wie war die
frage nochmals wieso kinross uns nicht
von den auffangbecken fernhält
naja wir zahlen den sicherheitsleuten
natürlich etwas damit sie uns warnen
wenn sie kommen auch dem chef des
betriebs schutz
[Musik]
wir kontaktieren sie und die sagen uns
welcher sektor für uns frei ist und so
können die gar in perus ungestört im
wasser fühlen
wer allerdings mehr gold zutage fördern
will muss durch enge röhren nach oben
klettern erklärt baulinie zuoberst ist
die ausbeute 50 mal höher als im
untersten becken jeden tag steigen etwa
70 personen durch diese röhren dabei kam
es mehrmals zu unerklärlichen
todesfällen durch plötzlich ein
strömendes gas paulinho erlebte einen
solchen todesfall erst hetzt sie sich
das wasser dann fühlten die zwei die
ganz oben waren ein jucken
aber keine hat derweilen gift gedacht
dann kippte die erste der oper besuchte
ihn zu retten märkte aber wie auch ihm
die kräfte schwanden
er kocht zum ausgang konnte sich aber
nicht aus eigener kraft aus dem noch
retten
wir halfen ihm hoch und dürften ihm
dabei den bauch auf
er schwankte hin und her
ich dachte schon jetzt steht er gleich
40 minuten später ist der tod der zweite
wird ebenfalls tot aus dem abflussrohr
geborgen
beide weisen vergiftungserscheinungen
auf die von einem gas herrühren müssen
ich denke die firma ist über die fälle
genau informiert die firma weiss also
wer wo am schürfen ist ja wir haben ja
kameras die ihren sicherheitsdienst und
ja auch unter uns gibt es welche die
schwarzen als carrera starb meinen sie
kinder aus wusste wende röhre war sicher
zweifellos aber wieso wien hat er denn
gestört ich vermute die firma na ja er
war berühmt
es gab gerüchte dass er millionen
verdient
dabei war ein ganz normaler karriere
eine von uns hartnäckig halten sich die
gerüchte kinross habe bewusst gas in die
röhren eingespeist der unfall sei
absichtlich herbeigeführt worden
wir haben kinross mit den vorwürfen
konfrontiert sie wollten vor der kamera
keine stellung nehmen zum tod der
goldschürfer führen sie aus sie hätten
keine eindringlinge auf ihrem areal
geschadet sie arbeiten mit den behörden
zusammen um diese todesfälle aufzuklären
giordani macht unbeirrt mit seinen
mitteln weiter er bringt die urinproben
seiner asien patienten zum labor um die
aktuellsten messwerte zu erfahren
sebastian hat 70 mal mehr sehen in ihren
knochen eingelagert als normal
ich bin der meinung dass goldabbau
prinzipiell möglich ist vorausgesetzt
das ist wird gemacht mit verantwortung
die schadstoffe sie entstehen durch
minen abbau oder aber auch einige steine
die müssen rio teilen also sofort
neutralisiert werden mobilisiert werden
damit dann die leute unter umwelt nicht
exponiert werden dass das erhöht
natürlich die kosten das kann für mich
viele minen bedeuten dass es
unwirtschaftlich ist aber es ist nicht
vertretbar nicht moralisch nicht
menschlich und nicht gericht gerichtlich
vertretbar dass man auf kosten von
gesundheit und umwelt gott abort
[Musik]
das